hey what is up guys I'm cubby HD here
and this is everything you need to know
about the newest version of iOS iOS 11
so I've done these same types of videos
for new versions of Android in the past
and as you've noticed while they're
probably usually a bigger numerical jump
forward they're also usually lately more
of minor additions and small incremental
improvements which are so really good
but not quite as exciting as a huge one
so iOS 11 just got the big unveil and
not gonna lie it's a pretty big update
both in new features and as a visual
refresh there's a lot of new stuff there
too and as a bonus most of your iphones
will probably get this iOS 11 update at
some point same thing can't really be
said I can't really say everyone's phone
is going to get that Android 8.0 update
so these are the top 5 new features in
maybe the biggest iOS update yet iOS 11
so number 5 is the way it handles
screenshots so screenshots in iOS were
pretty simple before you take a simple
screenshot and it goes to the gallery in
iOS 11 you take a screenshot and it sort
of floats down here to the corner where
you can take action on it whenever you
want you tap on it and then it expands
and gives you the mark-up tools - circle
stuff or highlight stuff or do whatever
you want with that before sharing it
which is pretty awesome and as a bonus
you can take multiple screenshots so
want to here you can move somewhere else
and take another screenshot there and
another one and they all show up at the
bottom where you can click in and view
them all mark them all up and then share
them one at a time or all of them etc
pretty useful now number four is the new
app store in iOS 11 well it's the same
app store but it got a huge visual
refresh of course I think a lot of
developers will appreciate this one
because the today section right over at
the Left which is the default upfront
can seriously highlight some apps big
time here these featured cards are
pretty good looking and of course you
can still browse the other categories
like you normally could does a dedicated
games section now so the new app store
is definitely very different if you get
used to it pretty quickly it's going to
be fun to browse kind of the same way
you did the old app store just in a
prettier way number three is the Siri
improvements so from the time I've
gotten to spend with the new Siri in iOS
11 it's a lot faster and marginally more
helpful so first off I can do
live translations now so I want to ask
it hey Siri how I say what's the weather
in German in German what's the weather I
believe you and did you see how fast you
reacted to the hey Siri Q like it reacts
again but it seemed to react within like
a second and start processing everything
into that and you can actually edit what
you said so technically if you want to
type to Siri you can modify your
question and do that too
so I think even just because of its new
sound speed it may be worth three
matching it or reak impairing it to the
Google assistant like I did in that
previous video and then maybe some other
assistants as well but it is still
invaded technically so I'll let that
fully-baked I'm just glad to see they're
still working on it so number two is the
visual overhaul there are so many new
little things that are visually
different in iOS 11 so from the minor
stuff like the bars at the top for your
signal instead of the dots and a couple
of new icons like the new calculator and
the way that looks and the new app store
icon and the new iTunes Store icon all
that stuff is generally flatter and
simpler and more cleaned up that's kind
of the theme here and the new lock
screen buttons are flatter as well so if
you have a pin to unlock your lock
screen those buttons are glassy and
clean and the dock at the bottom of the
home screen doesn't have any labels
anymore so it looks a little bit cleaner
there too they just did a lot of
cleaning up and then there's a lot of
new animation so check this out
waking up the phone with the power
button that's new unlocking is even
smoother I think double tapping the
multitasking brings in the cards from
the left and I I always thought that
scrolling was a little bit jittery but
it's very smooth now and just the
launching of apps has a slightly
different animation as well there is of
course the new font as well and iOS so a
lot of things are generally tidier and
cleaned up in iOS 11 and you notice that
of course with the many hours you put
into using it you'll notice way more
stuff but just right off the bat looking
pretty good and then the number one new
feature in iOS 11 is I guess the pretty
obvious one you probably saw it coming
is the new control center now when I
first saw it on stage at WWDC my initial
reaction is you probably judge from my
tweet was a little bit lukewarm it
didn't look all that weird in fact I
think it kind of looked a little goofy
when I first saw it but since I've spent
time with it in my actual hands and used
it my opinion of it has changed
about 180 degrees plus the old control
center and iOS was a bit finicky anyway
let's be real so this is a pretty
welcome change plus all the improvements
to it are pretty dope so this is the new
control center it's full screen it's one
screen and you might think this gap up
here is a poor use of space but it's not
because you can add toggles to it it is
actually legitimately customizable of
all the things for Apple to make custom
I wouldn't think this would be it but
this is awesome so you go into the
settings and you can add subtract or
rearrange as many of the toggles in
whatever order you want so this is what
it looks like the zero toggles added and
this is what it looks like with all them
on not that bad and then in the control
center itself all the control is pretty
intuitive I think so you tap any of the
toggles to enable or disable them like
before the rotation lock also has this
nice little animation and the brightness
and volume sliders are way easier you
don't have to go sideways and actually
swipe to the next screen plus you can 3d
touch any toggle and get way finer
control on a bigger scale sometimes with
more options appearing which is awesome
pretty good looking if you ask me and of
course you see the circle down here at
the bottom that's our new favorite
control screen recording so you can now
record your screen to a video without
any cables necessary and even turn the
microphone audio on and off which could
be super useful in a ton of ways wink
wink
snapchat doesn't seem to know you're
taking a screenshot wink wink it's
probably gonna be fixed with an update
but not yet wink wink
so let's customizable control center
while it may look a little bit weird at
first I think is the biggest and best
improvement to iOS so those are your top
five and like I said there's a ton of
other little minor stuff that didn't
even make this list that is still
greatly improved in iOS 11 you can now
click and drag multiple icons from the
home screen and put them together and
move them all to a new page at the same
time the new volume control and
everything else about the default video
player in Safari is way better there's a
new do not disturb while driving mode
that will probably honestly actually
save lives there's a files app for
looking through and organizing all the
files on your device and there will be
person-to-person payments through
iMessage and Apple pay which isn't
available yet in this version but still
seems like it'll also be pretty useful
so overall I'd say this is a pretty big
update just FYI this is still a
Developer Preview technically so more
thing
could be added or taken away in the
future don't want to get too carried
away but the full beta is coming later
this month and I think the full final
free release for all your iPhones will
be coming in the fall so let me know
what your favorite feature is what
you're looking forward to for me it's
recording things on the screen a lot
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching
Tut together the next one
[Music]